all right we are on the home stretch we
finally made it to question seven the
last
question but of course it has multiple
parts so let's jump in
with part a using euler's formula prove
that
cos of theta which you can see over here
on the left hand side is equal to
this unusual result on the right hand
side that involves the
exponential form of a complex number e
to the i theta plus e to the negative i
theta
on 2. now this question actually isn't
too
dramatic a lot of you were able to do it
successfully but
it's really important that i emphasize
because this wasn't always done well
the fact that we need let's get this
highlighter the right
color we need to make sure that the
reasoning in our proof is really clear
because when someone says
prove that something is the case you
need to show the logic you can't skip
any steps
um things that you might have normally
have thought oh this is just a given i
don't need to
say why this is true i don't need to
provide the substantiation for my claim
it's really important that you don't
skip over any of that so let me show you
the way
that i solve this if you come over to my
solution you can see
i've begun with euler's formula e to the
theta equal cos theta
plus i sine theta and by the way um this
is one of the reasons why
uh several students in an earlier
question forgot that when you have
a complex number an arbitrary complex
number in
exponential form it should have an r out
the front
because this is this enables you to be
any distance from the origin and any
argument
around the origin however euler's
formula
is stated just with a complex number who
has a
or that has a modulus of one so that's
what
what this formula looks like as stated
traditionally
so if that's e to the i theta then e to
the i negative theta
is and this is a step right here that
was skipped by many many students
it's cos of negative theta plus i sine
of negative theta so what am i doing
here
i am just using euler's formula to
convert straight from
exponential form to trigonometric form
to
a polar form now the step that was
skipped
is uh going on to this next one right so
this that i've highlighted here this
fact that
i take this argument negative theta and
i just substitute it in to the two spots
where the argument should be
that was often skipped and the reason
why that was an issue is because if you
just assume it's going to be equal to
this
then the proof is quite trivial and you
haven't really shown all the reasons why
it actually works
so what i've done from my line here is
to say that
cos of negative theta cos being an even
function
by definition let's use it in orange
over here an even function has
f of negative x being equal to f
of x so cos is an even function x
squared actually any
x with an even power is an even function
that's why they're called even functions
in the first place
so therefore i can do this substitution
here
and then in a similar way i've got i
sine of negative theta
sine by contrast is an odd function so
its definition for oddness is that f of
negative x doesn't give you
f of x that's even symmetry it's
negative
f of x out the front which you can see i
have substituted
in here so that was an important thing
to state
better responses always gave us the
reason why you could make this
substitution so
that's the first piece i now know what e
to the i theta and e to the negative
i theta can be substituted for so that's
me putting this in here
and the imaginary parts here are simply
going to cancel because we have
e to the i theta and e to the negative
i theta being conjugates of each other
so that's why
both of these terms go that leaves you
with double
the real component so that's why you can
see the 2 cos theta over here on the
left hand side
i want cos theta to be the subject so i
might as well get it over there
i've got e to the e to the i theta
plus e to the negative i theta which i
got from the left hand side no change
there and then i just divide through by
two so this was a pretty straightforward
two marks